[Music]
cristian podge knows what it means to
lead an insecure unstructured life he
spent more than three years hanging out
with this group of homeless people at
the + cent Mott in Paris he used to have
a well-paying job as a sommelier but
after his wife left him he started
drinking and when he could no longer pay
the rent he ended up on the streets this
is one of the places I slept in but a
few weeks later they installed these
typically anti homeless barriers they're
placed deliberately so no one can sleep
rough here the residents are a bit
ashamed of the barriers but they're glad
there are no homeless people sleeping
here they didn't bother anyone but it
was dirty I'm not sure what to think it
doesn't look nice but at least perhaps
now they're living in better conditions
than this entrance where there was lots
of garbage anti homeless barriers have
popped up all over Paris after Christian
tweeted angrily about barriers that had
been set up here where people sometimes
lie because there is warm air from the
subway he was able to make a change the
city of Paris had put in iron rods to
prevent access you can still see the
traces they would have stopped people
from being able to sleep there in winter
when it's cold I posted it on Twitter
and the next day the city authorities
removed the iron rods
Christian posted his first tweet three
years ago after his possessions were
soaked by street cleaners it was winter
and he wrote this is how the homeless
are treated in Paris within a few months
he had more than 30,000 followers
don't wobble monkey tweet I tweet in the
morning to say hello to the planet and
at night to talk about what was going on
on the street I take a picture of my
sleeping bag and say goodnight guys then
go to bed and people would answer
goodnight see you tomorrow
I thought it was cool with his tweets
Christian was able to draw attention to
the main problems homeless people face
in Paris something his friends
appreciate his friend Leonel doesn't
have a phone to get one he'd have to
overcome too many hurdles that appear
insurmountable to him I don't even have
a bank account I do but it's blocked my
papers are at the lost-and-found office
and I have to pay 11 euros to get them
back okay and on top of that they'll ask
me for my papers but I don't have them
people who live on the streets often
feel like pariahs but Christian posh has
given them a voice and his activism has
spread beyond Paris people send him
pictures of barricades from elsewhere in
France this one is from Nirvana in the
South it's true that the social media
have a certain power that can be
negative for big brands we'll see in the
next few days that events will che will
certainly get rid of those barriers
Christiaan is glad that his tweets can
change things for the better his own
situation has now changed for the better
too he's found accomodation at least for
the time being with a Christian aid
organization
[Music]
you